Chris Pratt is going on a three-week
spiritual journey the actor went on
Instagram on Wednesday to explain his
commitment to the Daniel Fast it's three
weeks of restricted eating and a focus
on prayer here's what he had to say okay
I'm hi Chris Pratt here
day three of the Daniel Fast check it
out it's 21 days of prayer and fasting
and it's gonna coincide also
coincidentally with the lego movie to
junket so by the time you see me I'll
probably be hallucinating stay tuned so
Chris and I actually go to the same
church here in Los Angeles and once a
year the whole congregation joins
together to do the Daniel fast the fast
is based on the Prophet Daniels fasting
experience in the Bible the idea is to
push the pause button on life so you can
get a little bit closer to God it's 50%
about food and 50% about prayer and 100%
about getting on track spiritually in
the new year
this year I opted out but let me tell
you last year I did the Daniel Fast and
guys it is no joke during the 21 days
you're only supposed to drink water and
stick to vegetables fruits whole grains
and legumes healthy liquid oils and nuts
and seeds guys it's basically just a
vegan diet with a few additional
restrictions so that means no meat no
animal products no dairy products no
sweeteners no refined and processed food
no deep fried foods no solid fats and
worst of all no coffee or alcohol this
year the fast last until the 27th but it
should be a cakewalk for Chris which I
know is a bad choice of analogy because
he can't eat cake right now
but still he's no stranger to watching
what he eats the actor opened up to et
about his strict diet and fitness
regimen for his role as star-lord in
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 and it was
intense
shirtless scene hat was coming did you
know the shirtless scene was coming you
know you got in the shape man no it's
always it's always good to know the day
that you're gonna be shirtless because
then you can really plan to try to peak
on that day right you kind of like lean
down a car like cut the carbs out what
do you do yes the dehydration is you're
cutting out
carbohydrates doing a series of salt
baths Wow like a spray tan listen man
listen you got to do what about like
push-ups before the scene I do do
push-ups pull-ups I have some dumbbells
there and you and you know that you know
the main thing you need to lose shame
you have to not be afraid to be like yes
I am the douche doing curls just perform
a scene we'll keep you posted on how
Chris is fast goes but make sure you
don't miss any updates by subscribing to
all things et I'm at Halle underscore
Stephens and I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]